My room.
It's big.
It's comfortable,...
...but I don't know.
The walls.
This chair.
Everything.
Move the bed.
Where?
How about under the window?
Put the hi-fi on the chest of drawers.
Put the chair in the corner.
I don't know.
Why don't you paint it?
Paint what?
Paint the room.
I don't know.
I'm not very practical.
I don't like painting.
I'm always too busy.
I don't really have time today.
I have a lunch appointment at one o'clock.
It's impossible!
Can we do it for you?
Really?
Yes.
Yeah.
Are you sure?
Of course we're sure.
What about the color?
Oh, I don't know.
Something nice.
Now, don't worry.
You go out.
Enjoy your lunch and leave it with us.
Thank you.
Okay.
Let's go and buy some paint.
Matt, do you want to come?
Yeah.
Do you want to get dressed?
Oh.
Right.